I'd like you to remember the unit circle
okay
the unit circle was important to us and
we're talking about tree because we said
look I've got out this is the unit
circle so this is in Cartesian space now
so I've got X's and Y's right I know how
to define any point not only in this
space but any point on this circle right
so for instance I could pick a point
over there and because I'm very good
with my unit second I've been using it
for a long time I know that its
coordinates are roughly exactly minus
root three or two
uh-huh okay now I can I can plot that
around go around I can I can check on
graphing software etc I'll get values
like that in other words I'm to finding
a point by horizontal good morning
horizontal and vertical displacement we
were used to calling these Cartesian
coordinates right but we learned that
there was another way of defining points
on this circle another pair of values
that I could use to uniquely define any
point where I am right instead of going
horizontal vertical instead of going
Cartesian right what was my other pair
of values I could use okay so I could
use actually on the unit circle a living
one value if I say there's a point over
here that's a point over here okay to
know where I am of the circle or what
really need is being called and I've
already told you the other piece which
is the radius right once you know the
angle and the radius you I can tell you
anywhere you are right so these are not
Cartesian coordinates they're also
called polar coordinates so we've got
cos theta sine theta here right so this
is this is the first time you meet a
parameter that we've worked in two
parachutes further okay now the reason
why I've joint is comparison is because
when we were starting to look at complex
arithmetic right we talked about what
happens with you
numbers we talked about what happens
with you subtract where you take the
conjugate etc right and then when we got
to multiplication multiplication we
noticed that the geometric meaning of
multiplying complex numbers has to do
with rotation do you remember that okay
in a sense complex numbers have rotation
baked into this structure in the same
way that integers write numbers with a
sign have Direction like back and forth
baked into their structure right you can
just add positive and negative numbers
together and you just go left and right
or up and down however you please it's
like it's like part of the DNA of the
number and the part of the DNA of
complex numbers is rotation okay so
being I can define numbers like points
on the unit circle like this I can
define contexts numbers which last last
few lessons we've been talking about
complex numbers as points I can do them
in exactly the same way okay so under
all of this right this is where we were
just this is my review and try to build
a reagent it's new I see you okay give
me a little subheading and finally this
is still what the proper heading we're
gonna get there in a second a little
subheading which is representations of
complex numbers
okay so the first one again which cars
place is right here and the one that you
already know is to say Z equals X plus I
Y that's one representation of a complex
number
now what are X and what are Y right x
and y ah they're about going this way
this much going this way this much
they're about that horizontal and
vertical dimension right
so x and y are horizontal and vertical
displacement how far do you open e go in
this direction
how far you'll be on this direction once
you tell me those two things I'll be
fine okay but there's another way of
stating this and it's on this table it's
on this form here right
I still need two numbers because I'm
still in a two dimensional space but my
two numbers are quite different they
don't correspond to horizontal and
vertical displacement hey Carlos root
number one and angle right here and
number two how far do I go in that
direction
right to the angle tells you which way
would you like me to face okay and then
this number here tells you how far
should I go in that direction okay so
instead of Z equals x plus iy I'm going
to say Z equals now I'm going to borrow
the same result that we established from
the unit circle right that caused
because of if I think I am a right angle
triangle here right you can see the
reason why cos theta is this horizontal
component okay because in this triangle
cos theta is adjacent over hypotenuse
right because you know
and up in here I've got to the vertical
part b sine-theta
alright let's extend it just a little
bit extend it just a little bit if I
knew a lot more the unit circle right
because the unit circle is just one
circle okay if I have a circle of radius
ah how does that change these how does
that change much for this okay good I'm
gonna be further away so it just because
they know I will be cos theta I'll be R
sine theta so I've got my coordinates
changing like so okay now therefore if I
write down X plus iy in terms of this is
X but my horizontal part and this is why
my vertical part right I would say well
the X part is R cos theta that's the
real part and I've got I times R sine
theta and that is the imaginary part
okay now I'll just tidy this up before I
I make a summary here I'll take my are
at the front cuz it's a common factor
and then you'll see this okay now I'm
going to write down one extra line after
this which I'm not a huge fan of but you
need to you need to recognize it okay
can you see you're going to get cos
theta plus I sine theta which
corresponds to well just where am i
horizontally where am i vertically but
I'm the key in terms of an angle down
okay because you'll get close and then
you'll get this ice I'd pop over and
over again right and it gets a bit
tiresome like you always have the same
theta
it might places because it has to be to
represent a point in two-dimensional
space some textbooks will contract-- the
cause and the I sine theta in to see for
cos i from budgetary s for sine and then
the angle is going to be the same and
this is pronounced ah since theta now
I've said right from the outset I'm not
a huge fan of this I don't like this as
a way of notation because I mean okay
what's good about it it's fast
it's fast and that's about it okay what
happens is you lose what's going on with
us this come from it starts to get more
towards that black box like it's just a
piece of magic in its notation I don't
know what it means but just does its
thing okay
I don't like notation like that okay
it's for the same reason the exact same
reason that I prefer saying this as
opposed to this okay I think they're
both fine and I will use both of them
and you'll definitely see both of them
so you need to recognize them okay but
you see how much more meaningful this is
right it's like why is it function I'm
doing something to it I can see there a
relationship between that and rise over
run which is gradient okay where is this
it's like oh it's just some magical
process and when you do it you just get
a dash on there and then this is a new
thing okay it's it's
instrumentally connected to the previous
thing through this mechanism of gradient
right and the same way here I will make
a habit I'm gonna keep writing it like
this okay
because I think F demonstrates for you
what's going on here this is what's
going on this is what's hiding
underneath this notation okay and this
kind of clouds it right but still you
need to recognize it because textbooks
we use it and all it means is this okay
so you don't need to necessarily get fit
but that's why I'm not easier even
though many other places go and if you
want to say sis theater then go for your
life okay but I'm not going to